all right Laura kognito here iron Lords
podcast Lords of gaming net and it was
this fine gentleman in the realm today
my name is Mitch Chapman I'm from zodiac
interactive and they're Jolly Roger so
tell us about this game what what is the
name of this game right here Lost Island
tell us about this so lost Islands it's
a kind of a concept that we're working
on we're trying to fuse the large-scale
multiplayer aspects of like the Barbra
Jean we're also aspects of other games
like say sea of thieves kind of
experience good so we want to do is not
encourage players to just kill each
other right but also to meet each other
on the battlefield and maybe make an
alliance and work together and you know
try and meet your goals so almost like a
battle royale meet sea of thieves as far
as not necessarily having to attack
every single person you come in contact
with where you can wave scotchy so is
like an automatic friend zone we have
infamy I like infamy let's get into this
man this looks pretty cool this looks
pretty cool so tell us right now what's
going on as far as uh where he's at in
this stage of the game now you can see
in the top right corner of the screen
there's the icon for the ship yes it's
got a time on it yeah what that means is
the ship will reach its destination at
that time and you're gonna have to get
to the ship together like an extraction
goddamn now I do have to say at this
point because this is a very early build
of the game it's possible we're going to
see some crazy bugs disclosure full
disclosure fun bugs are good
that's kind of where out right now
awesome awesome so we learned in the
control system here so again give us
some time alright so lost island give us
like a time frame I'm noticing some
medieval but you know his real arm or
pocket as we love medieval style games
we love that time but where you would
frame we're lords so tell it give us a
little bit background of this time frame
yeah so the dev team Johnny Roger this
is their first game but they have worked
on other games as dev teams before they
formed and they're very much interested
in that kind of medieval melee warfare
not kind of like cold weapon combat
that's kind of their their area of
expertise gotcha
so what they wanted to do is showcase
the game I'll film you if you want to
jump in with a co-pilot
Sarika no no no worries
yeah so the idea behind the game is
there's like tree agent factions it's
the ancient Europeans ancient Japanese
and ancient Chinese no ordinarily maybe
these factions wouldn't have met history
but this is kind of like a fantasy where
I'm saying you know they're naval forces
collided at a certain point and they
became shipwrecked on an island and
that's where the Schloss island the
concept again these these factions that
normally wouldn't come in contact with
each other based on time period but we
get to interact with them they're almost
a little get a little for honor vibe a
little bit there the previous games that
this team worked on also been compared
to the likes of for honor but it's
really because of the the historical
accuracy that they go for and the studio
actually is based in China
for all the weapons that they designed
in the game they also designed the
weapons like in reality okay and then
they go like and like use those weapons
on mannequins and stuff and now the
forest player count what are we looking
at one that style okay so we're looking
at a player 16 the full game is what are
we targeting possibly maybe 32 64
oh we go in there we still need to
balance stuff because we want to make
sure the game is firm I want to
encourage like the team play aspect
right rather than just a free-for-all
where everyone is killing everyone else
okay now here we go with some naval
action here now tell us about that
aspect of the game is there a naval
compound to ship the ship combat there
is there is ship the ship combi now this
particular ship is the exfil ship so
this is the big one that it's heading
towards its destination when it stops
right you'll be able to climb aboard and
then you have to survive until it
actually leaves cuz other players of
course I'm gonna do the same thing if
you look right here we've got a player
in a boat gotcha
so he's kind of like got the advantage
right now we've actually got two player
we got another boat there as well gotcha
so those guys could engage in warfare
there's cannons on those on those ships
element I like it's good to have like a
teammate because you can't fire to kind
of like just by yourself you know you
need to have the river got your buddy
over there with the cannons so let me
ask you this now I know you said about
player count now about coming into the
game like can you come in as a squad can
you light is it like teams of four or is
it everyone
individual on the when they come in and
then you have the about option to form
the Alliance is it that's though yeah so
right now it's it's the latter everyone
comes in individually and that's when we
put the emphasis on okay you want to be
part of a team right let's try and I
think
right and I do feel though that once the
game goes live we will include his
options where you can come in as three
main theme because of course we want to
play with a friend yeah I'm the Lord of
the cooperative experience I was hoping
that you might say you know three to
four players you know just hoping but
I'm glad I'm glad you said that as a
potential target this is awesome man
love the image now as far as our game
engine what are we using right now
for game engine right now what is this
tornado thing going on in the back but
this just relax
yeah we have it more as just a like a
visual flair so you can walk right into
that you're not going to be damaged
right it's just going to affect your
vision right put in the final version
you do not want to be near that tornado
it's gonna be when you see that coming
you want to be heading in the opposite
gotcha now I know we mentioned aspects
of battle royal and most battle royale
games have that whole mechanic of
closing in right and so will this game
have the loss I don't have any of that
no so it doesn't have the kind of
decreasing circle that you gotta stay in
however you will see on the map there
there are circles that do decrease yes
you don't have to be in those but those
mark like really amazing treasure that
booster
okay the reason that's important is
because the rescue ship it's a special
type of rescue ship it only rescues the
rich people yes this discriminatory
rescue ship what's going on if you pick
them off a bigger bar right and again in
game as far as like you know me give me
definition like what you're trying to
shoot for as far as endgame with this so
with the endgame like obviously the
rounds it's kind of like l-type rounds
most 25 minutes to half an hour the
endgame is going to be when you get
aboard that ship because there's only
one x will ship and so every other
player is going to be heading towards
that ship too so we found here at the
Pakistan who is that's really exciting
standoffs on the ship we're the guys who
breached at first they don't know okay
well these will these new players are
they going to board the ship or they
gonna attack me should i attack them
first right and there's these really
cool dynamics our form and we've had
some epic battles aboard the ship as the
ship is trying to leave you know so
that's kind of the endgame there and
multiple people can
so like I say it's not last player
standing done but only the one with like
the highest well scout who is very
ambitious title man I like now how far
along are we in development right now
early
and as far as platforms what are we look
around over right now PC but what are we
looking for is it PC only actually
showcase the game as part of their China
conference that's why we show case these
game packs before I get a lot of great
feedback feedback very early in the
development cycles incorporate that into
the game I want to give you guys a lot
of credit because on that aspect a lot
of dev sometimes are afraid in this
Gabri culture a lot of people are afraid
to put our early product so I got to
give you fearlessness in that regard
I wouldn't say fairness this there was a
lot of trepidation like we were we were
up I'd like half three in the morning
the boot just trying to like play the
game make sure the game works and we
were very worried that people would play
it see the junk Enis and you're like
okay I don't want to party but I think
pax players are quite savvy in the fact
that they realize that there's the game
is here and it can see beyond the books
and look at the experience because they
know that the books are again my only
criticism a small critiques would be
obviously I know this buzzing Jencks we
see if you know the water physics you
know maybe a little bit little work
there but as far as how ambitious this
game is it's a lot going on so I do have
to take that into consideration now real
quick of combat now the players we're
just gonna find it out as opposed to
trying at coins this year so we've got
some bloody battles going on
right there is a little bit of lag that
I notice right now so that's one of the
issues you want to iron out but you can
see here we've got some bloody combat in
jail here chilling though he is slaying
slaying for the booty again lost Islands
man looking good or very early stages we
like it what we're seeing man and again
earlier development long term target
possibly 2020 we're hoping the end of
this year but again like we've really
got to work on you know punishing the
game getting rid of all the bugs really
kind of I don't want to say if we're
definitely but hopefully and hopefully
under the end you look lost Isle of Man
looks great absolute pleasure thanks for
taking the time
I'll apologize man thanks a lot